RACHAEL O'MEARA: I'm Rachael
O'Meara and I'm really excited
today to introduce our
guest speaker at
Google, Robert MacPhee.
So a little bit about Robert
before we get started.
Robert is a speaker, author,
coach, and consultant.
His mission is to help people
connect in the world of
constant change.
He is the author of the book
"Manifesting for Non-Gurus,"
and we have some of those
here for later.
He also has a book and companion
journal for it about
how to quickly and easily
attract lasting results.
He's the former director of
training for Jack Canfield.
Jack, if you've heard of him,
he's the co-creator of a book
you may have heard of, "Chicken
Soup for the Soul"
and all those books in the
series, and also the author of
the book, "The Success
Principle." So
he knows his stuff.
He's also a founding member
of the Transformational
Leadership Council, a group
of the world's leading
authorities in personal and
professional development.
So without further ado,
please welcome Robert.
[APPLAUSE]
ROBERT MACPHEE: Thank you.
Thank you, everyone.
I am thrilled to be here.
I knew last night I was going to
be thrilled to be here, but
I didn't realize how thrilled
until I actually
flew in this morning.
I live in San Diego, and I flew
in early this morning.
And I realize while I was
driving here that you guys
have made my life so easy.
I just really connected, while
I was driving in traffic on
the 101, this is my opportunity
to give back to
you and maybe make your lives
a little bit easier, too.
Because I was jumping off the
plane, googling something
about my rental car company, and
then I was using my Google
Maps to get from where I
needed to be to here.
And you guys just make my life
so easy, so I really am
thrilled at the opportunity to
share some things today with
you that I think will make your
lives easier as well.
Would that be OK?
All right.
So we're going to go
through some things
today relatively quickly.
And I want to just set the stage
really quickly for how
we're going to do that.
What we're going to do today
is going to be focused on
creating results but also on
creating the experience of
life that you want
to be having.
When I looked at my work and
how I could really deliver
something that would be valuable
for you, it seems to
me that based on the nature of
this company and what's going
on here, and how quickly things
are moving, and the
amazing things that are
happening here, it's probably
not so much about creating
results as it is making sure
the results you're creating are
really in alignment with
the experience that you
want to be having.
So we're going to focus
on both of those.
And as we get started here
today, I would just invite you
to kind of put this conversation
into context.
To think about your own life,
your own work, maybe the team
that you're on, and just think
about what kind of new
results, what kind of
new experience, do
you want to be creating?
So that you can take what we
talk about today and just put
it into that context.
Because my intention is by the
end of the day today, or the
end of our hour together today,
you'll be in a position
to do some things a little bit
differently in order to create
the results you want more
quickly, more easily, and to
have those results really
be lasting.
So again, one of the things I'm
going to focus on today is
the fact that this can affect
you personally.
What we're going to go through,
what we're going to
talk about today, you could
definitely apply it personally
in your own life, in your own
position, in your own role.
But it can also affect
your team.
So if you're a member of a team,
if you're a leader of a
team, I would also invite you
to just look at what we're
going to talk about today
through that lens, of how can
this help my team?
And then I want to ask your
permission on two things.
One-- is it OK if we
go fast today?
You guys are fast, right?
That's what this company is
all about, is fast, right?
Because I really do have a lot
that I want to share with you
in an hour.
So just to let you know, I
am going to go quickly.
And the other thing, if it's OK
with you, if it's OK-- it's
lunch time.
Can we have a little fun?
Did you notice on that first
slide I shared at the bottom,
there was a thing about
the YouTube Week.
There's like some humor thing
going on this week and it
says, this had better
be funny.
So that's kind of the model.
This had better be funny.
One of the things we've learned
is that you actually
learn more effectively when
things are fun, when there's
laughter and fun involved.
So I told you it's going to be
about results and experience.
It's also going to be focused
on practical and
implementable.
I want what we share today to
be something that you can
literally put into action and
put into use right away.
The title of today's
presentation is "Mastering the
Art of Living a Purpose
Driven Life.
And again, we're going to focus
on purpose, but I want
to start with that
first word--
mastery.
And by mastery, I mean
attracting the results we want
quickly and easily.
You all know the people
who do this.
They just make it look easy.
Things happen.
They always have the resources
that they need.
Things are easy and effortless
for them.
That's the result we're
looking for.
I'm going to add one other word
in there, which is I want
to help you do this in a way
that those results last.
So it's not just a
one-shot deal.
So did everyone get two wine
corks on your chair?
So I'm going to ask
two things.
One, can I have maybe four
volunteers who would be
willing to come up to the front
of the room with your
wine corks?
And I'm going to ask everyone
to set down your things and
stand up with your wine corks.
So can I get four brave
volunteers who would be
willing to just come up,
two on each side of me?
And I'm going to demonstrate
mastery for you.
I'm going to give you
all the opportunity.
If you would, just set your
stuff down, stand up with your
wine corks.
OK, so we have four
brave volunteers.
Let's hear it for
our volunteers.
They have no idea how brave
they really are right now.
So I'm actually going
to pull a chair.
This is probably an OSHA
violation, but this'll help
you guys who are further back.
What I'm going to
ask them to do--
and you're all going to
do this with me--
is you're going to take your two
wine corks just like this,
between your thumb and
your forefinger.
Can you all see that?
And then you're going to take
them apart just like that.
OK?
So I'll show you guys this.
It's hard for you to see.
You're going to start like this,
and you're just going to
take them apart like that.
OK?
So we start like this, and we
take them apart like that.
You start like this,
and you just take
them apart like that.
AUDIENCE: Wait, how?
ROBERT MACPHEE: OK.
So everyone was able to
do that, no problem?
By a show of hands, how many of
you were able to do that?
One, two, three.
OK.
You might have gotten the
left-handed corks, so you
might need to switch them from
one hand to the other.
OK.
So can you see that I've
mastered this?
We're talking about
mastery, right?
Of all the things I could have
mastered, I picked this.
But you can see that
I've mastered it.
But like many things, when you
tried to do it the first time,
maybe it wasn't quite as
easy as it looked.
How many of you got to this
spot, right here?
Right?
And how did that feel?
Just give me some words to
describe how that feels.
AUDIENCE: Stuck.
ROBERT MACPHEE: Stuck?
AUDIENCE: Frustrating.
ROBERT MACPHEE: Frustrating.
AUDIENCE: Silly.
ROBERT MACPHEE: Silly.
OK.
So is that how we feel when
someone comes in and
says, oh, it's easy.
They come into your
office, they show
you how to do something.
It's easy.
Just hit Enter and it's done.
And you go--
but then when you try to do
it yourself, you have this
experience, right?
So for my four brave volunteers
up here, and for
you guys, what do you need from
me to take your next step
towards being able to master
this silly skill?
What would be helpful?
AUDIENCE: Show it
to us slowly.
ROBERT MACPHEE: Show
it to us slowly.
See, now this is one of the
interesting things that we see
about this metaphor.
The women always
say two things.
One is, do it slowly.
And the other one
is, do it again.
So I'm just saying, this may
be a metaphor for more than
just the mastery thing that
we're talking about, here.
But anyway, men usually have a
completely different response.
But better instruction?
Would that be helpful?
OK.
So here's what I'm going
to ask you to do.
Take your--
I'll just stand up here
again, so you can see.
Take your thumb from one hand
and put it on the palm end of
the cork, the end of the cork
that faces your palm.
Now bring your other thumb
around so it's
also on the palm end.
Make sure it's on
the palm end.
And once you have your
thumbs in place, just
reach over and under.
Sometimes it's easier with
your middle finger.
And they should come
right apart.
Did you get it?
Got it?
Get it?
OK.
So by show of hands, with a
little bit better instruction,
how many of you were able
to get it that time?
OK.
So most of the room.
Now the rest of you, I'm going
to ask you a favor.
Please don't leave here
today without
knowing how to do this.
Because I came here to help, to
support, to make friends.
I don't want anyone walking out
of here going, that was
the stupidest thing I ever--
[GRUMBLES].
OK?
But here's the thing.
You've had the experience now.
Have you mastered this?
For those of you who have done
it, have you mastered it?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: I wouldn't
say mastered.
ROBERT MACPHEE: Not quite
mastery, right?
You can do it.
You know how it works.
It's maybe still a little
awkward, still a little
uncomfortable.
But I believe there are four
things-- you guys can go ahead
and have a seat, if you want.
Actually, everyone can have
a seat, if you want.
I believe there are four things
we always need to be
willing to do in order
to achieve mastery.
And you guys already
were willing to
do a couple of them.
The first thing we need
to be willing to do is
try something new.
So here comes this crazy
guy from San Diego.
He puts two wine corks
on everyone's chair.
You have no idea what this is
about, but you're willing to
pick up the corks and give
it a try, right?
Simple as that might seem,
you're willing to do that.
Number two is you're willing
to ask for help.
Now could you have figured
this out on your own?
Maybe.
You guys, pretty smart group.
I'm going to tell you I believe
you could have figured
it out on your own.
There's only so many fingers.
There's only so many
ends of the corks.
You could have figured it out.
But would it have
taken longer?
And can you get it done more
quickly and easily by asking
for help, getting some
instruction from someone who
knows how to do it?
The third thing is be willing
to be uncomfortable.
In order to really master
anything, we have to be
willing to be uncomfortable.
Did I make you a little
uncomfortable?
Especially the four of you who
were brave enough to come up
to the front of the room?
Not only can you not do it, how
many of you did that thing
where you kind of looked to the
left, looked to the right,
and see if you're the only
one who can't do it?
But it's a little
uncomfortable.
It's a little awkward.
And that is the case whenever
we try something new.
And then why is it
so easy for me?
AUDIENCE: Practice.
ROBERT MACPHEE: What's that?
ROBERT MACPHEE: Practice,
right?
Thank you.
Sometimes people say, you must
drink a lot of wine.
But that's not it.
[LAUGHTER]
ROBERT MACPHEE: Of all the
skills I could have mastered,
this is the one.
I learned this years ago, and
I saw the metaphor in it.
I had that physiological
experience of what it's like
to be uncomfortable.
And when we're uncomfortable,
what do we do, a lot of times?
Go right back to what we were
doing before, right?
So the fourth thing that you
need to be willing to do in
order to achieve mastery is be
willing to do it repeatedly.
Practice, practice, practice.
And any of you, whether it's
this silly little cork trick,
or whether it's a skill at
work, or a skill in a
relationship, or mastering
health and fitness, whatever
it might be--
if you're willing to try
something new, if you are
willing to ask for help,
if you're willing to be
uncomfortable, and if you're
willing to do it persistently,
you can absolutely
achieve mastery.
So today when we're looking
at mastering living a
purpose-driven life,
that's what I mean.
Being willing to do all
four of those things.
So of those four things,
what do you think
would be the most difficult?
Which would be the
hardest one?
What's that?
AUDIENCE: Be uncomfortable.
ROBERT MACPHEE: Be
uncomfortable.
AUDIENCE: For me, I think
it would be number four.
ROBERT MACPHEE: Practice,
practice, practice.
This is different for
different people.
But I'm going to put this
out as a possibility.
I believe number three,
the willingness to be
uncomfortable, is the one
that gets more people
stuck than any other.
The willingness to get outside
of our comfort zone, to
stretch, to do something
different, to risk the
response of other people.
And if you look at the other
three and ask yourself, why
aren't people willing to
try something new?
Often, it's because it's
uncomfortable.
Why aren't people willing
to ask for help?
It's often because it's
uncomfortable.
And why aren't people willing
to do something repeatedly?
It's because it's
uncomfortable.
So the next thing I want to take
a look at is this issue
of being uncomfortable.
What does it really mean?
How many of you have ever had
someone say, you need to get
out of your comfort zone?
You could do more.
You could expand yourself if you
were just willing to get
out of your comfort zone.
And it sounds good, right?
But what the heck does
that even mean?
Like how do we know if we're
outside of our comfort zone?
What is that all about?
So I want to share a model with
you that zeroes in on
this issue of being
uncomfortable.
And most of the time,
what makes us
uncomfortable is change.
So I'm going to ask you to
do something else here.
Let me ask you all to take your
hands and just put them
together like this.
And look down at your
hands and notice
which thumb is on top.
Just notice which
thumb is on top.
Now how many of you had your
right thumb on top?
And how many of you had your
left thumb on top?
And did we have anybody--
sometimes we have people who
kind of layer them right
next to each other.
Did we have any of those?
OK.
So for those of you who had your
right thumb on top, what
that means is that
you're a thinker.
You're an analytical, kind of
a think it all through, go
through all the steps
kind of a person.
If your left thumb was on top,
that means you're sexy.
[LAUGHTER]
ROBERT MACPHEE: And if you were
that rare person who has
their thumbs right next to each
other, that means you
think you're sexy.
[LAUGHTER]
ROBERT MACPHEE: No, actually,
that's totally made-up.
But take your hands like this
and put them together, just
like we did before.
Notice which thumb's on top.
Same thumb, or different
thumb?
Same one, right?
Now I'm going to ask you to take
your hands and take them
apart, and move all
of your fingers.
Don't just move your thumbs, but
move all of your fingers
so your other thumb is on top.
And how does that feel?
AUDIENCE: Weird.
ROBERT MACPHEE: Strange?
Weird?
Uncomfortable?
Different?
What do you want to do?
Put them back the other
way, right?
Aahhhh.
I believe, in this simple little
metaphor, is why most
people don't achieve what they
really want to achieve.
They'd rather go back to
being comfortable.
Now what would happen if we just
held our hands in this
new position for maybe
10 minutes?
It would become comfortable.
It actually becomes comfortable,
if we're willing
to do that.
So this is what we mean by
getting outside of our comfort
zone, being uncomfortable.
It's just that willingness
to do that.
So I'm going to share a
four-part model with you
that's going to take a
look at comfort zone.
And I already asked you to
consider what kind of result
you want to create in your life,
what kind of new result,
what kind of new outcome
you want to create.
So as we go through this, I'm
going to encourage you to look
at it again through that filter,
that lens, of what you
want to create.
What's important to you.
So it's going to start
with results.
We're going to start in the
lower right-hand corner of
this diagram, with results.
And we're going to look at what
goes on that leads to
creating new results
in our lives.
Now what has to happen
before any new
result is going to happen?
What do we have to do
before any result is
going to show up?
Any new result?
AUDIENCE: Take action.
ROBERT MACPHEE: What's that?
ROBERT MACPHEE: Take action.
OK.
So I have a copy in
my book here.
And it is signed, good.
And I'm going to give you a
signed copy of my book, for
two reasons.
One is because that is in fact
the word that I was looking
for, that we have to take action
before we're going to
get any new results.
And the other reason I'm
sharing a book is
because it's lunchtime.
You guys have been
working hard.
It's the middle of the day.
And you're thinking,
wait a minute.
He asked a question.
She answered the question.
She got a free book.
[LAUGHTER]
ROBERT MACPHEE: Next time he
asks a question, maybe I
should answer the question.
So just going to kind of try
and keep you engaged here.
But isn't it true?
In order to create results, we
have to get into action.
Now I wrote this book.
It's called "Manifesting for
Non-Gurus." And I normally
don't even use the word
"manifesting" in a corporate
environment, because it
has me back out on the
street really quickly.
Because manifesting has
this vision, right?
Like I'm just going to sit at
home, I'm going to be on my
couch, I'm going to hold my
hands in the right way, and
put on the right music, and
light the right number of
candles, and all my dreams
are going to come true.
But in my experience
with manifesting,
that's not it at all.
It absolutely has to come from
taking action, taking what I
call inspired action.
So here's where it gets
a little tricky.
What comes before any
action that we take?
What precedes any action
that we take?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ROBERT MACPHEE: You're
ineligible.
You already have a book.
[LAUGHTER]
ROBERT MACPHEE: It sounds
like she may have
already read the book.
Now I've got two people back
here raising their hands.
How cool is that?
What was the answer?
AUDIENCE: You have to really
think about your [INAUDIBLE].
ROBERT MACPHEE: You have to
really think about it.
All right.
So I can't do my Tony Robbins,
like charge up the aisle.
Can you guys pass that
book back there?
And again, thank you.
Thoughts.
Before any action we take,
there's always some thinking.
Sometimes it's very
well-thought-out, very
methodical, very orchestrated.
We all think it all through.
And other times, how many of you
have ever said the words,
what was I thinking?
What was I thinking
before I did that?
But there's always
some thought.
And if you notice, we
think in pictures.
We think in imagery.
So the next, as we go through
this, is to think, well, what
leads to the thoughts
we think?
What is it that's putting these
images in our minds that
are dictating the actions we
take and the results we get?
AUDIENCE: Observation.
ROBERT MACPHEE: Observation.
AUDIENCE: Desire.
ROBERT MACPHEE: Desire?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ROBERT MACPHEE: Emotion?
ROBERT MACPHEE: What's that?
AUDIENCE: Stimulus.
ROBERT MACPHEE: Stimulus?
AUDIENCE: Problems.
ROBERT MACPHEE: Problems?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Experiences.
ROBERT MACPHEE: Experiences?
OK.
So this could be like
a whole hour-long
workshop, in and of itself.
And I'm sorry to say, there's
no free book here.
Because the reality is there's
so many different things that
are creating the images that
we hold in our minds.
And I'm going to lump a bunch of
them into a category that I
call external influences.
External influences.
This is your boss.
This is the media.
This is the internet.
This is the television, the
radio, the newspaper, the
magazines, the billboards.
Your friends, your family,
your coworkers.
All are bombarding us with
these external influences
that, in some cases, people are
letting dictate the way
they think, the way they
act, and the results
that they're getting.
See how that works?
So there's got to be a
better way, right?
Because we don't want those
external influences to be
running our lives.
And this is where we connect
into the real central theme of
today, about purpose.
Because the one thing that
probably has more influence
than anything else on the
thoughts we think, the actions
we take, and the results
we get is our beliefs
about who we are.
Our "I am" beliefs.
And when we allow our beliefs
about who we are to really
dictate, to override, those
external influences, and
determine the way we think,
the way we act, and the
results we get, then we tend
to live a life that's much
more purpose-driven.
We're going to have the
experience of life that we
want to be having.
I used to do a lot of work with
people in the health and
fitness industry, and this
was eye-opening for them.
Because what we've really
explained here is two
expressions that I know
you've heard before.
Have you ever heard
the expression,
"self-fulfilling prophecy"?
So we just defined that.
Because if I have a belief that
I'm overweight, out of
shape, and I don't have time
to exercise, I will think a
certain way.
I will take certain actions--
or in this case, maybe not
take certain actions.
And the results that show up
will tend to be in alignment
with, I'm overweight, out
of shape, and don't
have time to exercise.
If, on the other hand, I think
of myself as an athlete, will
I think differently?
Absolutely, right?
Will I act differently?
And will the results that
show up in my life
tend to be very different?
So it's a self-fulfilling
prophecy.
And the other thing that we've
defined here is the term that
we started with.
Again, you've all heard
the expression
"comfort zone," right?
And of all the things I'm going
to share with you today,
this is probably the one to make
sure that you capture.
Write this down.
Because what a comfort zone
really is, when you are in a
comfort zone, is when your
beliefs about who you really
are match the results that are
showing up in your life.
And this can be in the area of
finance, your income level.
If your belief about what your
appropriate income level is
matching what's showing up in
your life, you tend to be in a
comfort zone.
And there will usually be
resistance to change.
In terms of health,
your body weight.
In terms of your
relationships.
Whatever your beliefs about
who you are, if they're
matching the results, even if
it's not what you want, you'll
tend to be in a comfort zone.
So a lot of people do--
let's use New Year's resolutions
as an example.
Health and fitness, New Year's
resolutions, January 1.
Some external influence comes
in and says to this person
who's overweight and out of
shape, says you know what?
You ought to lose some weight.
Yeah, I really want to
get in better shape.
So they think differently.
They get an idea.
I could join the gym.
They take an action.
They go and join the gym.
They start exercising.
They might start losing
some weight.
They might start
seeing results.
But where are those people
on February 1?
We don't know where they are.
We just know where they're
not, right?
They're not at the
gym anymore.
And I believe this
is the number one
reason why that's true.
The number one reason why
people start an exercise
program and quit is because they
don't address their own
beliefs about who
they really are.
They're swimming upstream.
They're dragging an anchor along
with them called, I am
overweight, out of shape, and I
don't have time to exercise.
And until they change
those beliefs.
So what we encourage people to
do, in my work, is to start
with that "I am" belief.
To start by declaring, I
am worth twice as much
money as I am making.
Or I am my ideal body weight.
Or I am an athlete.
Or I deserve to be in a
nurturing relationship.
Whatever it is.
Now pop quiz.
If I encourage anyone in this
room to do that, to change
their belief about who
you really are--
how many of you talk to
yourselves, by the way?
Anyone talk to yourselves?
OK.
I've learned that there's
usually, in a room this size,
about three or four people who
are thinking to themselves,
talk to myself?
Do I talk to myself?
I don't think I talk to myself.
[LAUGHTER]
ROBERT MACPHEE: But the reality
is we all talk to
ourselves, right?
So if I say to you to make
this new declaration--
double your income, lose
the weight, get into a
relationship, whatever it is--
what does the mind say?
What's the conversation?
What's the response?
AUDIENCE: OK, how?
ROBERT MACPHEE: OK, how?
I have three kids.
My youngest is now 15.
When she was younger, she used
to say, yeah, right.
Because there's that
self-doubt.
There's, you've tried
before and failed.
You've never been
able to do this.
What makes you think
you can do that?
Trying to keep you in
your comfort zone.
Because the belief that you're
declaring about doubling your
income or losing the weight or
whatever doesn't match the
results that are showing
up right now, right?
Because your income right
now is what it is.
Your body shape, your weight,
is what it is right now.
So this is you trying to stay
in your comfort zone.
But here's the beauty of this
model, in terms of creating
lasting change, is that when
people are willing to start by
declaring a new belief, and
really connecting to that and
recognizing how important it is,
and to hold on to that and
allow the new ideas, the new
thoughts, the new approaches
to emerge that will lead them to
taking the actions that are
necessary to create change, to
do things differently at home,
at work, wherever it is, and
then to allow those new
results to show up that'll match
the new belief, then
we've created a new
comfort zone.
So you've literally created
a result that matches your
desired belief, and now you
let go of the resistance
because you've created
a new comfort zone.
That make sense?
And again, it works in any
area of your life.
And again, if you look at this
in the context of your teams,
it can work in groups just as
much as with individuals.
Some of the conflict and issues
and turbulence that
shows up amongst teams is
because we have all these
different perceptions of
who we really are.
And when the team gets really
clear about a shared vision
and purpose, and stays clear
about that, it's much easier
to go through this whole process
of ideas and actions
and results.
So again, what I coach people
to do is start in that lower
left-hand corner, with "I am."
Our beliefs about who we
really are.
And my work is really focused
in that area.
I mentioned that I
have this book.
I also have a partner journal.
And when I was halfway through
writing the book, I created
this journal.
Because like I told you guys
at the beginning, I'm
passionate about people
implementing what I teach.
How many of you have heard
the term "shelf
help?" Ever heard that?
I don't want my book to
become shelf help.
Which means people buy it with
the best of intentions, they
go home, they put it on a shelf,
and they never read it.
That doesn't do anyone
any good.
So the journal is a
way for people to
implement the approach.
And what I'm going to do now
is I'm actually to show you
what that approach is, the
five-step approach that I
teach people to lead more of
the kind of life that they
really want to be leading.
And we're going to go through
five simple steps.
So the first question that
I teach, that I use--
and this is the connection
from the previous model--
is the question, who am I?
Who am I?
Now, if we were to walk out on
campus here and just start
asking people, who are you?
Who are you?
What kind of answers
do you think
would come up for people?
AUDIENCE: Job title.
ROBERT MACPHEE: Job
title, right?
AUDIENCE: Their name.
ROBERT MACPHEE: Their name.
It's usually the
roles we play.
And that is one area of
who we really are, the
roles that we play.
But I believe this is really
more how we express who we
really are.
In my book and in the journal,
we look at the question, who
am I, from four different
points of view.
The first is our roles.
The second is our skills and
talents, the things that we're
really good at, we tend
to identify with.
The third is what we
call contribution.
And this is one of the really
powerful elements.
When we really are connected to
our sense of contribution,
what we're here to do, how we
can improve other people's
lives as well as ours, we get a
strong sense of who we are.
And then the fourth part is
what we call core self.
Who we are beyond this
human experience.
Beyond the body, the car we
drive, the clothes we wear,
the thoughts we think,
all that.
Who are we?
And it's really quite profound
when people connect at a deep
level to a sense of
who we really are.
So I invite you--
again, I do a two-and-a-half-day
weekend
workshop, and we spend a whole
day on this question.
Who am I?
We have an hour today.
So there's not that much we
can really do with it.
But I invite you in this moment
to just ask yourself
that question.
Who am I?
If we had more time, I'd
actually partner you guys up
and have you sit across from
someone and ask the question,
who are you?
Who are you?
Over and over again, for
about a minute to a
minute and a half.
And the experience, for most
people, the first thing that
comes up, is what
you guys said.
It's the roles.
It's the things we do.
But when someone keeps asking,
and you have to keep coming up
with different answers,
we tend to go deeper.
We tend to connect to who we
really are, what's most
important to us.
Things like the contribution
that we really want to make.
One of the things I've loved
about looking at this company
is that I know that's
a really important
part of your culture.
Making a contribution.
Doing something worthwhile.
Impacting other people's
lives.
I would imagine most of you come
to work on a daily basis,
knowing that you're doing
something much bigger than
what your day-to-day
responsibilities are.
And that's what we mean by
really being connected to that
sense of, who am I?
And it's also what I mean by how
it affects organizations
as well as individuals.
So who am I?
So this second question's a
little more straightforward.
It's called, what am I
intending to attract?
And I kind of asked you guys
this question at the beginning
of the presentation today.
What are you intending
to attract?
What is the result that
you want to create?
And what I'm going to
ask you to do is--
a lot of you don't have
something to write with.
But if you can, write it down.
And in this moment, declare
an intention.
Declare a desired result.
A specific and measurable
result.
Just think for a minute about
what that would be.
What are you intending
to attract?
It could be something
personal.
professional.
It could be health-related.
It could be
relationship-related.
Whatever it is, in your
mind or on paper,
declare your intention.
And I invite you, as you do
that, to kind of peek back
over your shoulder at the first
question we looked at,
and ask yourself, is that
intention in alignment, with
who you really are?
The approach I teach is to get
people to be really clear
about their intentions, but also
to really know that those
intentions are in alignment
with who they really are.
Because that's a very powerful
place to act from.
Does everyone have something
in mind?
OK.
So how many of you would be
willing to share your
intention with the group?
Even if you might
get a free book?
No, I'm kidding.
Oh, another hand popped
up back there.
OK.
So I'm not going to ask you
to share your intention.
But what I am going to do--
I want to ask for some feedback
from those of you who
didn't raise your hand.
And remember, I asked you
how many of you talk to
yourselves?
And you all pretty much
raised your hand.
We all talk to ourselves.
When I said, how many of you
would like to share your
intention, would be willing
to share your intention?
Something happened there.
A conversation started, right?
And I'd just like to hear some
examples of what you told
yourself, that said, no,
don't raise your hand.
What was your reason for not
raising your hand and sharing
your intention?
And there's no right or wrong
or good or bad answers.
I just want to get a sense of
what kind of things come up
for people.
AUDIENCE: I wanted to hear
what other people had.
ROBERT MACPHEE: You wanted
to hear what other
people had to say.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Gets really long,
really quickly.
ROBERT MACPHEE: OK, so it
got kind of long-winded.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Only going to
make sense to myself.
It was an inner thought.
ROBERT MACPHEE: OK.
So it's only going that
make sense to
you, versus the group.
All right.
AUDIENCE: It's too revealing.
ROBERT MACPHEE: Too revealing,
too personal.
OK.
Anything else?
AUDIENCE: A little
bit shameful?
ROBERT MACPHEE: What's that?
AUDIENCE: A little
bit shameful?
ROBERT MACPHEE: A little
bit of shame about the
choice that you made.
OK.
So here's what I'm going
to ask you all to do.
First of all, I'm going to teach
you a little bit of a
facilitation technique.
Because I'm about to a total
control of the room go to you
guys, instead of me.
In a minute, I'm going
to ask you to stand
up and get a partner.
But before we do that,
I want to teach
you a little technique.
And you're going to be talking
amongst ourselves.
And in order for me to get
control of the room back, and
keep us moving forward and
finish on time, I'm going to
raise my hand at one point.
And when I raise my hand, if
you see my hand go up, I'm
going to ask you to raise
your hand as well.
And when you raise your hand,
you're going to pretend like
there's a string attached to
your hand and your jaw.
So when your hand goes
up, your jaw shuts
and you stop talking.
Right?
So this is just a way-- you guys
are going to be talking
amongst yourselves for just a
minute, and it's a way for us
to just bring the attention back
to the front of the room.
So let's try that.
Go ahead and just turn to the
person next to you, or the
person behind you, and just talk
to them about anything.
What you're having for lunch,
whatever it might be.
When you see my hand go up--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ROBERT MACPHEE: All right.
Very good.
All right.
So I'm going to ask everyone
to stand up.
And find yourself a
partner and sit
down facing your partner.
The reason I asked you to stand
up first is for those of
you who are in between--
like this person goes that way
for a partner, this person
goes that way, and you're
standing there alone, once you
have your partner, sit down
facing your partner, it's
going to make it really easy for
the people who don't yet
have a partner to
find somebody.
So just sit down facing
your partner.
You guys are good.
Very good.
OK.
So I need to--
let's see.
In each partnership, I need you
to figure out who has the
longest hair.
Person who has the
If it's the exact same length,
it would be the darkest color
that we'll go with.
And that person is going
to go first.
And what you're going to do is
for one minute, you're going
to share whatever it is you're
comfortable about your intention.
What came to mind for you?
And if you don't want to,
if it's something really
personal, and you don't want to
go all the way into depth
about it, you can give
kind of an overview.
But just for-- and I'm going to
give you like 45 seconds.
Just share with your partner
about what came up for you
when you declared
that intention.
OK?
So person with the longest
or darkest hair
is going to go first.
You have 45 seconds.
Go ahead and begin.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ROBERT MACPHEE: OK.
I totally looked at the wrong
number on my clock, and I have
no idea how much time
that actually was.
But it feels like about
45 seconds.
So we're going to switch roles
now, and if you were
listening, you're going
to be sharing.
If you were sharing, you're
going to be listening.
This time, it really
will be 45 seconds.
Go ahead and begin.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ROBERT MACPHEE: OK, great.
Thank you.
Now I want to hear from a couple
people, especially
those who didn't raise your
hand-- which is the vast
majority of the room, so that
won't be a problem.
But how did it feel to share
your intention, or part of
your intention, something about
your intention with
someone else?
First of all, everyone OK?
Everyone all right?
We all survived that?
[LAUGHTER]
ROBERT MACPHEE: All
right, good.
How did that feel?
How did that work?
What happened?
AUDIENCE: Felt better one
on one, [INAUDIBLE].
ROBERT MACPHEE: OK, so it
felt better one on one.
You had a little chance
to explain it.
What else?
AUDIENCE: I think I realized how
many things are connected
to my intention.
It's not really-- you think
it's just about work.
It's really not.
There's so many other factors.
ROBERT MACPHEE: OK, so you
gained clarity about your
intention by sharing it with--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ROBERT MACPHEE: Well, a broader
perspective, though.
You realized more about it.
AUDIENCE: Lot of factors
[INAUDIBLE].
ROBERT MACPHEE: OK, good.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Love sharing personal
thoughts with total strangers.
ROBERT MACPHEE: You love sharing
personal thoughts with
total strangers.
All right.
We'll work on that later.
Perfect.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ROBERT MACPHEE: It was what?
AUDIENCE: Good to go second.
[LAUGHTER]
ROBERT MACPHEE: Good
to go second?
Why was it good to go second?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ROBERT MACPHEE: OK.
So he survived.
It was OK for him.
No, that's a good point.
Because once we have a chance to
kind of see how we respond
to someone else, we can imagine
maybe they'll respond
the same way, right?
AUDIENCE: I realize other people
have the same issues
and concerns that I do.
ROBERT MACPHEE: Realized other
people have the same kind of
issues that I do.
They want the same
kind of thing.
How many of you had that
experience, where you realized
there was some similarity
of intention?
OK.
So again, we could take sharing,
we could do a full
hour just on this.
But I asked you to do
that because every--
I actually thought it might
be different today.
Every time, I think it
might be different.
This is Google.
These guys are all going
to raise their hands.
They're all going to
want to share.
But there's something that tells
us it's not OK to share.
Now should you share your most
important, your most personal
intentions with everyone?
AUDIENCE: No.
ROBERT MACPHEE: No.
Absolutely not.
But aren't we all surrounded
by like-minded, supportive,
encouraging people somewhere
in our life?
And if we're willing to share
our goals, our intentions, our
desires, our dreams,
we can get help.
Did anyone find that the person
you shared with said,
ooh, I can help you with that?
Did that show up anywhere?
Well, that just blasts my whole
theory about Google
right there.
Come on.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: We're good
listeners.
ROBERT MACPHEE: But
that can help.
Really good listeners, OK.
You guys really follow
instructions well.
That's great.
But do you get a sense
of, its OK, right?
To stick your toe
in the water, to
share with one person.
And granted, I asked you to do
something that was a much
bigger stretch, to stand
up in front of the
whole group and share.
That's a different question
than just
sharing with one person.
But you have the experience.
Most people aren't willing to
share even with one person.
So I want to give you the
experience of what it's like
to share that intention, to
anchor it in more deeply, to
get more clear about how
important it is to you.
And hopefully get a
clearer vision.
Get clarification and feedback
from someone, get support and
help, whatever it might be.
So that's our intentions.
The third question of the
approach that I teach, after
we look at setting our intention
and making sure that
intention is in alignment with
who we really are, is to ask
the question, how will I feel?
How will I feel?
And when we look at
manifestation, when we look at
creating new results in our
life, we look at things like
the law of attraction, I believe
this question about
feeling and emotion is really
the language of all this work.
That when we connect deeply to
the feelings and emotions we
most want to experience, we
start attracting more of that
into our life.
I work with people all the time,
and they've got, like, a
pocketful of 3x5 cards with
their visualizations, their
affirmations.
They've got them all
written down.
They'll come up to me and
they'll go, I heard this guy
Jack Canfield speak, or I read
your book, or whatever.
And I know, I've been doing
my visualizations, my
affirmations, every
single day.
And this stuff doesn't work.
And I'm thinking to myself,
what's the feeling and emotion
that this person is
experiencing?
There's anger, there's
resentment, there's fear,
there's doubt, there's worry.
And I believe that person is
sending a message to the
universe saying, please send me
more anxiety, fear, doubt,
worry, pain, all of that.
Because that's the feeling
and emotion that they're
experiencing.
So of all these questions that
I teach as part of the
journal, "How will I feel?"
is the simplest one.
But I believe it's the
most powerful one.
When we really connect to the
feeling and emotion of what it
will be like to earn more money,
to be our ideal body
weight, to be in the perfect
relationship,
how will that feel?
To me, that's what really
gets the wheels moving.
I'd love to spend more
time on that, but.
OK.
The fourth question, the fourth
step that we look at,
is called letting go
of attachments.
How many of you would agree
that we have a tendency to
make things more difficult
than they need to be?
Anyone else, or is
that just me?
OK.
So attachments is
how we do that.
Attachments, the way I define
it, is any way that we're
using our attention, our
thinking, our beliefs, in ways
that are not supporting us.
This is things like needing
to figure out how to do it
ourselves, needing to figure
out all the steps before we
get started, needing it to
happen now, being worried
about what other people might
think, judgment of other
people or judgment
of ourselves.
These are all ways that we
can use our attention
that don't serve us.
That are slowing us down, rather
than speeding us up.
So part of my work is about,
first of all, identifying what
those attachments are, and
second of all, looking at ways
that we can let go of
those attachments.
There's some amazingly powerful
resources out there
to help us to recognize what the
attachments are that are
getting in our way, and
ways to let go.
Again, in an hour today, we
don't have time to really go
into depth on that.
But when you start recognizing
and being aware of what your
own attachments are, what are
the things that are getting in
your way, and get better at
letting go of those, it's
amazing how you can accelerate
your results.
One thing that I do in my work
that's a little bit unique, in
terms of this area of letting go
of attachments, is this is
where we focus in on gratitude
and appreciation.
I believe that gratitude
and appreciation--
first of all, it's kind of a
nice bridge from the feeling
step into this look
at attachments.
But sometimes when people set
a goal and they realize that
it's really in alignment with
who they are, they connect to
the feeling and emotion of how
they really want to be
experiencing life, and they know
that this goal is perfect
for that, they can get to
the point where they,
like, really need it.
Like, I need it to happen.
Like, it's so important.
My life won't be complete
unless I have it.
And I believe gratitude and
appreciation is the way to
stay out of that trap.
Because we really
don't need it.
Our lives, everyone in this
room, our lives are
amazing right now.
And if we pause and allow
ourselves just to be grateful
for the blessings that we have
now-- the friends, the family,
the opportunities, where we
live, this amazing company
that you're working for, this
environment here that's just
so remarkable.
When we pause and allow
ourselves to be grateful, we
can settle into a state that I
call high intention and low
attachment.
High intention--
clarity, focus, certainty
about what
you're working on achieving.
But low attachment.
I don't need this.
My life is amazing
just as it is.
And when you really settle into
that state, it's amazing
how powerful we can be.
How many of you have ever dealt
with a salesperson who
needed to make the sale?
Anyone?
OK.
And how many of you have dealt
with a salesperson who was so
passionate about what they do,
so unattached, they were just
so passionate about what they
do, that you bought something
from them that you
didn't even need.
Right?
That's the difference that
I'm talking about.
High intention, clarity,
focus.
On purpose, but non-attached.
And then finally, the fifth step
that we teach is called
taking inspired action.
Which brings us back to
that four-part model.
No new result is going
to be showing up
without taking action.
But the difference is with this
kind of approach, with
asking ourselves these kinds
of questions, we are taking
action from a different place.
From a different
point of view.
I tell people what most people
are doing out there, when they
get around this kind of
goal-setting, personal
development kind of work,
is they're looking
at step number two.
They set a goal.
And then they skip right
ahead to step
number five, take action.
Right?
And these are the people that
are working hard, lots of
effort, will power.
No matter what, I'm
going to do it.
And they may be getting results,
but in terms of the
experience that I talked about,
they're rarely having
the experience that they
want to be having.
And they're rarely getting
results that really last.
So I encourage people to take
a look at the difference.
Like what would the difference
be if I really was
clear about who I am?
If I was connected to the
feelings and emotions that I
most want to experience?
And if I had increased my
awareness of and inability to
let go of the attachments
before I take action?
And how different
would that be?
So I had one other piece.
Oh, we have time.
Cool.
Thought we were out of time.
All right.
So when I get into inspired
action, I rarely have people
go, action, that's bogus.
I just want to sit on the
couch and meditate.
I don't want to take action.
People know they need
to take action.
So I want to share with
you something.
Does everyone have something
to write on?
So I'm going to ask you take a
piece of paper and a pen or
pencil, and be ready to write.
Because I'm going to have you
do an exercise related to
multitasking.
Now how many of you, personally
or professionally,
are put in a position where
you feel like you need to
periodically multitask?
Anyone?
OK.
So how many of you consider
yourself to be really good
multitaskers?
Anyone in the room think
you're a really good
multitasker?
Couple of them.
OK.
So I'm going to give you
a point of view about
multitasking.
I'm going to ask you to write
out a sentence in a minute.
And this is the sentence.
Now everyone always
wants to cheat.
So I can't really see very well,
but you're going to have
to wait until I say go.
OK?
I'm going to ask you, in a
minute, to write this sentence
out but to do it in
a very unique way.
You're going to write it
one letter at a time.
And then after you write the
letter, you're going to write
a number below it.
It's going to go
just like this.
You're going to start with the
letter M. And then below it,
you're going to write
the number 1.
Then you're going to go back up
to the letters and write U,
and go down and write 2.
L, 3, T, 4.
I hope that's as far as I went.
Yes.
So you see how that works?
Letter, number, letter,
number.
And I'm going to time you.
OK?
And when you're done, you're
going to-- don't start yet.
There's always people
who want to cheat.
When you're done, you're
going to stand up.
And I will tell you
how long it took.
So keep track of how
long it took.
So you all ready?
Don't start yet.
Don't start till I say go.
Oh, I saw that.
All right.
All right, so ready?
Go.
31.
35.
Remember how long it took you.
So if you didn't finish, go
ahead and just notice how far
you got in one minute.
So just make a note of
how far you got.
And everyone else
can sit down.
Now I'm just curious, how many
of you are doing this on a
phone or a computer?
That's so cool.
All right.
That's a first for me.
I'll share that with all the
other groups I do this with.
So now I'm going to ask
to do it differently.
Same task, but you're going
And again, don't start
till I say go.
I'm going to time you again.
Anybody notice the level of
anxiety that started to show
up when other people finished
ahead of you?
Right back to second
grade, right?
OK.
So this time, the same thing.
You're going to write
all the letters and
then all the numbers.
And this time, you're going to
write the letters first.
Write the whole sentence
from start to finish.
And then you're going to write--
there's actually 27
numbers, so you're going
to go from 1 to 27.
Don't start yet.
I see those pens come up.
So when I say go, you're going
to write the whole sentence
and then the numbers 1 to 27.
Same thing, stand up
when you're done.
Ready, go.
Stay standing.
18, 19, 20, 22, 23, 24,
25, 27, 28, 29, 30.
OK.
So again, if you didn't finish,
notice how far you got
in 30 seconds.
So have a seat.
So what was the difference
between the two?
What's that?
By a show of hands, how
many of you got
further the second time?
And what was the experience
like the first time?
What was the experience like of
doing one, then the other,
then going back and forth?
AUDIENCE: Frustrating.
AUDIENCE: Very frustrating.
ROBERT MACPHEE: Frustrating.
Someone else up here
said frustrating.
What other--?
AUDIENCE: I noticed there was a
mental jar, soon as I got to
the two-digit numbers.
ROBERT MACPHEE: A mental
jar when--
OK, so a little something
different.
You got to two-digit numbers
and that threw you off a
little bit.
All right.
So kind of like the corks--
this particular task won't
take you very far in life,
but the experience, the
physiological experience of
realizing what it's like to go
back and forth from one task to
the other, versus making a
commitment to start at the
beginning and finish a task
before you move on to the
other, is an amazing
productivity tool.
An amazing way to get
more done in a
realistic amount of time.
And for people-- and
I'm one of them.
I still get pulled into
multitasking.
I teach this stuff.
But any time you're checking
your email while you're on a
phone call, this is exactly
what you're doing.
This exercise comes from someone
named Dave Crenshaw,
who wrote a book called "The
Myth of Multitasking." And he
says there's no such thing
as multitasking.
There's only switch-tasking.
Switching back and forth.
And it wears you out.
It exhausts you.
I skipped over a step of this,
which is, if I had let you all
go to the end, and I took a
little poll about how many
numbers there actually were, I
probably would've gotten 25s,
26s, 28s, 29s.
Because when you're going fast
and trying to do it, it
affects your accuracy,
as well.
So the degree to which you're
able to commit blocks of time,
finish something start to
finish, is the degree to which
your productivity will
really go up.
It'll help you get more of the
inspired actions done.
So we're pretty much where
we need to be.
Were right at the
top of the hour.
And I wish I could be here
all day, all afternoon.
But I'm going to finish with
a couple questions for you.
First of all, as we look at
the five steps, as the
questions, who am I?
What am I intending
to attract?
How will I feel?
Letting go of attachments
and inspired action.
And as we look at those four
things I pointed out that we
need to be willing to do in
order to achieve mastery--
the four steps of trying
something new, asking for
help, being willing to be
uncomfortable, and being
willing to be persistent--
my question for you is what's
most important for
you to focus on?
That's nine different things.
Five steps and four things
that you need to do.
For everyone in this room,
there's an area to zero in on.
For some people, it might really
be getting clear about
your purpose.
For other people,
it might just be
about taking more action.
For someone else, it might be
that being willing to be
uncomfortable.
But again, I want everyone to
leave here with something
clear and concrete that you know
you can focus on, that
you can do.
That you can even work on and
focus on for the rest of your
day today, and say, I would
be willing to--
again, not multitask for
the rest of the day.
Or get clear.
Take 10 minutes and really
get clear about that
question, who am I?
Whatever it is.
But for you, out of those nine
questions, what is most
important for you?
And the other question I would
leave you with is-- what if?
What if you led your life from
more of a place of clarity
about who you really are, what
your intentions are?
More of a connection to those
feelings and emotions you most
want to experience?
If you were more aware of the
attachments that get in your
way, and more able to let go of
those attachments, and if
you were taking more
inspired action,
what would be different?
How would things be different?
And the same thing with those
mastery questions.
I will support you, help
you, in any way I can.
As you're looking at that one
thing, as you're considering
what that one thing is that
you'll focus on, Rachael and
her department actually very
graciously purchased 25 of my
books to share with those of you
who are here in the room.
So if you're willing to come
up to Rachael and to share
with her what you're going to
focus on, what is that one
thing that you're going
to focus on?
What's one thing you took from
this conversation today that
you feel like you
can implement?
She's going to give you a
free copy of my book.
Now don't climb all over each
other in order to get those,
but anyway.
The other thing I have here is
I have copies of the journal.
If you're interested in using
the journal and the book
together to implement this
approach, to try it out
yourself, the journals
are normally $19.95.
You can get them for
$10 here today.
For anyone who's watching online
who's not in the room,
there's a website called
manifestingbook.com.
It's on the slide.
And if you click on the image
of the book at that page,
manifestingbook.com, you'll get
an offer for a book and a
journal-- the books are
normally $15, the
journals are $20.
You'll get the book and the
journal together, signed from
my office, for $20 if you
click on that link.
So I'm available to help
in any way I can.
Would love to stay connected and
support you in any way I
can, and that's one way.
I wish I had time to tell
that story, but I don't.
I'm going to finish on time.
I don't know.
Do we have time to take
a couple questions
if people have them?
AUDIENCE: So one thing I've
noticed when trying to
multitask is that it's a lot
harder to do two verbal tasks,
like talking with someone and
reading, versus talking with
someone and driving or
playing a video game.
I was wondering if there's any
scientific basis for that, if
there's sort of like a language
part of the brain?
ROBERT MACPHEE: I don't know the
science behind it, but I
would totally agree with you.
And I think it kind of depends
on how you define
multitasking.
I'm definitely that guy who's
going to put a load of laundry
in and have that laundry washing
itself while I'm
working on something.
I'm definitely that guy who's
listening to something on tape
while I'm driving, because I
don't want to just be wasting
my time listening to sports
talk radio or
whatever it might be.
So there's elements of kind of
complementary activities.
And I think you bring up
a really good point.
If we're using the same area of
our brain, if we're using
the same kind of communication
skills, if we're trying to
carry on one conversation at the
same time we're carrying
on another conversation, that's
the stuff that's really
going to drive us crazy.
And not being a smart aleck,
but if I was speaking
somewhere else and someone asked
that question, and they
were really interested in the
research, where do you think
I'd tell them to go?
[LAUGHTER]
ROBERT MACPHEE: I mean,
it's all accessible.
I think one of the most amazing
things about the world
we live in right now--
and this is part of the reason
I titled my book "Manifesting
for Non-Gurus"--
is we don't need
gurus anymore.
We all have access to all the
information we could possibly
need, and then some.
And we can indeed create
the lives that we
really want to live.
AUDIENCE: Do you have
a formula for
multitasking better?
I've heard--
I've heard something
like 60/40/20.
Like doing something for 60
minutes, then another priority
for 40 minutes, and taking
a break for 20.
Is there something that
you've found is
maybe better than that?
ROBERT MACPHEE: So I'm glad you
clarified the question.
Because the answer to "Is
there a way to multitask
better?" That's an easy
question, called no.
Because again, there's no such
thing as multitasking.
But you bring up a good point.
The research that I've seen
says no more than 50--
5-0-- minutes to really expect
yourself to be focused on any
given task.
And then we need to get up.
We need to walk around.
We need to take a breath.
We need 10 minutes of a little
bit of a break before we come
back to whatever it is
we're working on.
But most people don't even give
themselves that kind of
block of time.
I'm talking about, you know, the
phone is off, the door is
closed, everything is shut
down, so you're totally
focused on something
for 50 minutes.
It's amazing how much you can
get done if you do that.
If you try to do that for two
hours, the mind can't keep up.
You can't do that.
So 50 minutes, and then take a
break, and then come back, is
the number that I've seen.
So thank you all very much.
[APPLAUSE]